[Music]
Nintendo's upcoming limp centric
fighting game arms is shaping up to be
an entertaining competitive experience
for the switch while it's relatively
easy to pick up its mechanic's offer
subtle dose of nuance of complexity
thanks to the freedom to customize your
fighters glove configurations before
each round with each glove sporting a
unique combat advantage the ability to
mix and match them is one of arms as
major highlights is a fighting game thus
far surprisingly arms also sports
additional competitive modes the tube we
got to try with the basketball inspired
hoops mode in the shooting gallery esque
skill shot mode but hoops was by far our
favorite mode to play in it you fight to
throw your opponent into a basketball
hoop the first to reach 10 points or get
the most points by timeout wins hoops
was consistently exciting especially
when you managed to win a game by making
a successful three-point buzzer beater
[Music]
do you think arms has what it takes to
be a well-adjusted fighting game let us
know in the comments below and while
you're here give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes got a bounce to tango
Mike all bite
[Applause]